politics with America you're seeing
what's going on with the election one of
the uh Vantage points you have is you're
not there it's kind of like it's your
problem you guys deal with it I'm over
here on this side
from your perspective YouTube comes out
hey all the election stuff you guys
talked about that we would ban it and
take you down you guys can talk about it
now because we want a balanced argument
from both sides okay no problem
um
who do you see what do you what are your
thoughts on the Trump today 2024
DeSantis Biden how do you see this thing
planning out politics is is so
interesting it's it's so messy I mean
obviously I'm a trump supporter I
believe in Trump I like the scientists
and the things he did
I I'm not going to choose between Trump
or DeSantis I think if one of them won
if any of them won it would be fantastic
for the world I think YouTube taking a
back step is actually extremely
important symbolically it'd be
interesting to see if they keep that up
post this election seeing what happens
with this election that'll be very
interesting uh but I think it's
certainly a massive symbolic step back I
remember when I got canceled nobody
talked about Rumble nobody talked about
kick nobody talked about even you got
valuetainment no disrespect you were a
lot smaller than you are now of course
it's crazy how fast Alternatives have
popped up and I'm only saying this
because I do feel like I literally said
I remember my exact words I said there's
pressure behind the dam everyone's tired
of it all it takes is a crack and when
there's a crack there'll be a flood and
the crack in the dam will be a man who
is more famous once he's canceled than
he was before he was canceled that's
what I said now they're trying to put me
in jail which is making me more famous
again I'm not saying it's all because of
me but I'm saying there's definitely a
public Consciousness switch where the
the arbitraries of Truth are having to
backstep now they've overused their
power they over set the power exactly we
said they would and now they're allowing
open discourse so I hope that America
has a free and fair election that's what
I'm praying for I think every country
should have a free and fair election
especially when we're going to fly
fighter jets and drop 500 000 bombs on
Farmers who've never made five dollars
in their day and into the guise of
democracy but we're going to bother to
do that that we should at least have a
democracy ourselves so I think a free
and fair election will be interesting
and I think the will of the people
should be done and that's how America
was built and founded and that's what I
would like to see and I do think that
America does lead the public
Consciousness overall as a whole I know
what you're saying about me being over
here but I do think that which which
side wins does have an overreaching
effect overall on the entire planet
America is still the most powerful
country on Earth it'd be very
interesting to see
what happens in 2024 we'll put it that
way my neck is an application which
allows you to take a minute to connect
with influencers from all around the
world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]